three people including two teenagers
have now been charged in last weekend's
mass shooting in Alabama and in Texas a
man fired at a group of cheerleaders
after one of them started to open his
car door by mistake Mark Strassman has
the latest
in Texas eighteen-year-old Peyton
Washington remains in the ICU after
being shot early Tuesday her teammates
say she was with a group of cheerleaders
when one of them mistakenly tried to get
into the wrong car in a grocery store
parking lot authorities say the person
in that car Pedro Teo Rodriguez Jr
opened fire striking Washington and
another teammate she's a mentor and a
role model to so many kids in this
industry she's an amazing athlete
amazing kid in Upstate New York a judge
denied 65-year-old Kevin Monahan's
request to be released on bail in the
shooting death of 20-year-old Kalyn
Gillis prosecutors say Monahan opened
fire after Gillis and a group of friends
accidentally drove up Monahan's driveway
Saturday night Gillis was struck as they
were turning to leave my daughter was an
honors student
she had hopes and dreams of becoming
she had hopes and dreams of becoming a
marine biologist
and this man
took that away from us
and in Dadeville Alabama Brothers Travis
and Tyrique McCullough 16 and 17 years
old along with 20 year old Wilson Lamar
Hill Jr have been charged with four
counts of Reckless murder following
Saturday's shooting that killed four
people and injured 32 others at what was
supposed to be Alexis dowdell's sweet 16
birthday party there's an uncut cake an
unburned 16 candles that never got lit
Lexi's brother was one of the victims on
her 16th birthday party she'd been
helped by her brother as he took his
last breath I'm glad that they found him
dado told us of her family's grief over
her brother and relief his alleged
killers are behind bars do you know
these guys I don't have no clue who they
are at all never heard of them before
they weren't invited no police haven't
commented on the motive behind the
killings or whether there's a
relationship between the suspects and
the people they allegedly shot images
still seem unreal
for any of this so I'm just still trying
to process it but I just take it day by
day because I know it's going to be
really hard for CBS mornings Mark
Strassman Dadeville Alabama